I got this record and I wanted to tell
you I can't wait man I've been so
excited for I've been trying to get this
whole day to go I couldn't wait for this
day to get done forget
[Music]
[Music]
if you can't be unstoppable
that Mexi very nice to meet you man
pleasure being how are you thank you
brother
goddamn I'm excited to become a now
let's go [ __ ] cry this I'm excited
thank you for stopping by for a favor
for us I listen same from me you guys
are doing good [ __ ] sorry I'm like
trying to us trying to get like health
[ __ ] insurance here like trying to
activate my [ __ ] I mean I'm willing
little bit you might get in our do it
yes do it let's do it you're the man
here we put you right back there that's
cool yeah super cool how are you I've
got I'm Jason Jason's my pleasure thank
you so much alright you are shoot what
the [ __ ] I know where so should I say I
didn't see that perfect is like such
like you I would take it how are you how
you know really good I watched shameless
be Angus but um Reiner's he was with the
Rangers now he went to Texas he had
explained boys but my entire rookie year
in second year I just watched film with
him literally I was in with the eternal
arc insane Michael and I thought the
exact same because I tried to mimic
everything he did and now is my rookie
ride knowing you need him on this
podcast that's very important to be a
huge theme of what you can learn from
people's actions you could change lives
by having Shane on the show other people
yeah all humans lives based on the way
you mapped against Shane that's what
people so this a good segue I tell
people the real I do a daily vlog on
YouTube is don't listen to what I'm
saying
watch what I'm doing right like if I'm
going all-in on Instagram stories right
now and putting out 20 pieces of content
a day that means I think it's smart
right if I'm going on the best podcasts
in the world not this one but another
one it's other yeah others yeah you know
that means that I think it's smart you
know you knew that he was a big-time
player and had a huge success
and you watched it I'm stunned by how
many people would rather read a book
then watch the behavior of the people
that are winning
[Music]
and you that yoyoyo Instagram good to
see you good to see you the biggest
question so many people struggle with
how to actually start and do and make
these things happen for themselves so
how to start dropping Leben am ma a
little 11 a.m. or 11 a.m. Monday
beautiful day in city of you rock
hope you guys have a beautiful day do
something crazy go out and say hello to
somebody you haven't sent her lotion so
to somebody your office right now or in
your neighborhood or the coffee store
and say what's up come but we never talk
anymore and while once in a blue moon
you sell something really expensive
that's fun yeah and I need a store too
I'm not kidding I love retail retail the
it's [ __ ] frontline and anybody can
walk in the door and they might be a
lunatic that's just got a bellevue they
might be a billionaire who's visiting
from tokyo and you have no [ __ ] idea
and that trains an interesting muscle in
your intuition in your way you engage
with people it's changed a yeah yes I
got trained right and it's really it's a
special thing that is very seriously the
biggest single sale that I ever made my
library in the store not on the Internet
was a guy that came in with combat boots
and dragged mud into sport not joking
right forty thousand dollars one drop
level and not a kick Charles Pearson if
you're watching Charles Pearson stock
guy who came up to me and said do you
want me to keep an eye on the guy
literally when he walked in he thought
the guy might steal something right like
they're gonna laugh of this I may want
to give you a quote for the book cool I
never do it people ask me all the time
but I just really like this subject
matter good first meeting I like Michael
a lot smart guy good vibes makes sense
that he's so deep into empathy right so
I always intuitively liked him
[Music]
I know it goes
you can leave these battle scars but
you're never gonna break I know like I
know what he do
we're working the model and we're
selling [ __ ] much like it's works like
it's [ __ ] work
okay
[Music]
would you do it
it was actually
and I saw me
me a last meal
hello iris really how are you I just
wanted to thank you such a lot of my
sniffing Freddie talks about has really
inspired me in my life and respected so
first off way is little baby Thanks
like that's the gear but I think you
probably again I think you may have but
like you'll get it's real it's real and
when you know you have a new video
tomorrow you get a little less romantic
and right that's that but the marriage
of the both correct the reason we can
win is right now we're just putting out
like we're not winning to the level we
deserve
[Music]
oh yeah
we
and I have it
[Music]
oh yeah
like savages so funny company I go great
good how we doing good to see you nice
digs
thank you not too shabby huh to Cheviot
oh man absolutely incredible
yeah it's pretty rad you love what you
built the people that review to people
that shoot with you do the people that
run the accounts - incredible incredible
that's how I know that what you're doing
with culture is not [ __ ] thank you
buddy that has scaled an organization I
know how [ __ ] hard that is we've done
an amazing job and this you already know
but they like each other and that should
time around like whoa it's really like
thank you mommy thank you I appreciate
thank you just having you guys in the
corner of my eye while that was going on
might have been the best part I'll see
you guys later
I don't think he looked like Sheamus the
wrestler right I think you do you
remember Sheamus the big Irish wrestler
the last 10 years in WWE think you're
fit you look like them no I'm trying my
man thank you my man he's had a phone
number that I called they're doing a
nice job here like it's coming along way
better than I thought it would
how's your day hanging in
[Music]
Thank You Valerie Cameron true Gary
Vaynerchuk said to son Tyler hi I'm Gary
the what are you working I do a daily
vlog somebody's filming and then just
running to a business meeting with
clients gosh no one interrupted a good
picture and of course of course
awesome thank you thanks for saying
hello jittery work nice mean you man
real pleasure
yeah have a good time take care you know
when I'm in their partner from propeller
oh no Peter briefly I remember very
quickly I remember in the beginning when
I first got there I remember you kind of
like in that beaded area yeah I remember
hi Mary Mary I mean look it yeah yes sir
my man Thank You America so luck on the
new one yes how my said what's up
yo come in and you're really well how
are you Thank You Man what's your name
kind of like saying all your videos man
their motivation I appreciate it thank
you thank you yes I'm going to the
meeting with a client now from Diageo is
on the phone and we're gonna have a nice
little uh little drink here summer to
summer time is in the air your rock
which I love and then I'm going to meet
with a business connection for another
dinner and drinks and then I'm going to
meet up with UD rock and we're going to
go and I go into the studio do our thing
good time to be alive you know I doesn't
buckle lovin leaving cuz you supposed to
ride you to touch them kissing feeding
please use a coaster ride if it's not me
anybody do when it must be true the
Bordeaux knives it so don't like or
mushroom Club that's no L may be
surprised so well god damn I've been
moving make this been tough goddamn I've
been losing nothing summer what I need
the more peasantry that a man who are
working now I hear why you sleep don't
let's go back from a really great dinner
then I told you met earlier really
interesting power player good dude
now the studio in Midtown and see me
here before the second trip here
directed this time pajama voice up Berg
and it makes the magic happen are you
dude you rock okay
[Music]
Oh for better hey boy hey ty okay I'm a
guy ravines of it what am i man 100 you
good good real good
hey I'm handsome my man how you are Gary
you know G's in one semester real
pleasure
however what's not oh great are you
other person with no growth whole PI
crew behind the gore empathically
tragedy Mormon community really 40 so
many things I literally would give me
okay now let me see you put your head
here cuz I wanted by man oh yeah was it
by yeah what it fly
thank you God comedy today up there
yeah yeah whatever I'm trying mandals I
saw your muscles the last time you were
through okay so I got this record and I
wanted to tell you I can't wait man I've
been so excited for I've been trying to
get this whole day to go I couldn't wait
for this day to get done forget people I
just came back from Africa to all right
when we got when we going to Ghana
Nigeria June 2nd we're done going June
2nd to Ghana Ghana Ghana
uh-huh what are you gonna do out there
I'm on the board of something called
pencils of promise
digital release of a big fish there's a
digital album pretty much for sale or
just out put out for sale yeah through
what I can
iTunes Spotify I'm told let us let us
know how we can help
absolutely I mean obviously it's not
like I mean it's I mean I can really
help so she ate some of your part of
ones that I can really help so this is
like what one of the real studios right
because we've come through here a couple
times now it's like there's no one to
[ __ ] I should get dr. Rocca the first
time is that right yeah I'm doing Big E
I rent no that was the real moment like
where [ __ ] got weird except it yeah man
I wish I could rap you could wrap your
probably I have a lot to talk about -
what was what he's motioning I wish I
could admit I would I really like I can
like with that said I'm really sure I
know I know that it doesn't like I know
when I speak and that like it comes off
like comedy and like improv like I know
what I can you know self-awareness you
know we could say R is maybe
[ __ ] that is why I love that if I could
rap I'd be [ __ ] rapping I would have
wrapped it all up by now I would just
kill people I would have sold all my
businesses I would be on my way
but I hate Wall Street those [ __ ]
cheap
that's why I major that's a real bar I'm
thrilled to put that you're on your way
jeez are you away I really want it I
want it I want it I wish you know you
guys can't trick me into it I know I'm
not but why are you talking cuz you
don't go over there to buy some
motivational service I'm already angry I
haven't gotten the booze be angry I'm
going to listen to it a couple times to
like really get let's start from the top
again what summer click or whatever it
is 1 activate every one song gets used
on a videogame that becomes the biggest
video game like one show uses like a
like a hook in the background one
celebrity lips me on musically like it
just you just don't know where it's
going to come from my concern is that no
one can over saturate because of supply
and demand of the noise that's what I've
been thinking a lot about weird what
Kyle in the other day no matter how big
outside of like three artists I don't
know like look how much [ __ ] you're a
puss out for sure trade books out
[ __ ] a like I think he's whatever put
out a lot of content no but he puts out
a lot of music it's just there's so much
noise now definitely you know what's but
you know what's been [ __ ] with me
summer I haven't talked a lot about but
this is the same thesis so my whole life
everything about even right now I still
just care so much about my legacy so
much I think about is what's gonna
happen when I die and I think like a
good depressive obsession so listen this
you're like ash I'm like you know how am
I gonna be as big as Genghis Khan Oh
like it will I be remembered like
Michael Jackson oh yeah well that's
that's how I thought about it like I was
like that's right I was like if I die I
really want the world to stop for a
couple days and like beyond like back in
when I was even like 10 15 years ago CNN
[ __ ] show [ __ ] I want my [ __ ] kids
cry and like I want the world stopped
then this is real Princeton David Bowie
died right I guess last year and 16
right like I got [ __ ] up I'm like [ __ ]
people when we give a [ __ ] for like nine
hours
and this is how I think about music we
us concept research business videos
musicians we have our own pride and our
own egos and our all lives and we think
oversaturation and I think yeah but like
there's just so much now it's not like
I'm [ __ ] when I grew up when like you
want the Sam Goody one [ __ ] the new
you know like nas album came out and
like like seven albums get like should
just come at these kids 24/7 and it
becomes a supply and demand game and my
big thing is so wait you're putting on a
mixtape and an album how many songs good
26 any songs you actually have I know
you do my man I think you can make 27
songs tonight whatever you know what I
mean like and I'm always wondering like
I said to Kyle when I was looking the
other day I was like 20 of 7 biggest
songs never saw the day of life you know
that was that [ __ ] the other day when
they found like you know six months ago
you know they found all the music and
it's yeah and I'm always like what if
his [ __ ] seven best songs never
strike yeah right cause he's my second
guess I promise you the 11 best hooks
you ever came up with in your head you
just thought about it like you just you
know you move them I know I do like some
of the best [ __ ] I ever thought of I
know I lost so I vlog so I blog now you
should vlog man you're real interesting
you would kill it did you
multi-dimensional people don't know
people kind of know but not as much come
in here it'll help me
Oh what's his name uh gotta love that do
that possibly Oh custom auto yeah custom
model you're like my custom model I love
it
you're basically talking about what we
were just talking about I get it as no
sleep I mean sleep but it's like what
you can do always is keep going
not so much it's my number just like
I'll go oh I know how to drop one liners
so I know you know how I communicate
mm-hm soon
oh yeah using iPhones haha I can't read
for this I'm so excited I can't breathe
I'm more talking about this in my next
book you know oh yeah I got a really bad
book I'll get it early you know uh I get
a lot of people coming to me
conversation when I was at your office
is that right and they love it people
appear same for me go that's why I was
telling you about like people were my
man you really sit on something you're
young to to um your baby you can't wish
so much already that it [ __ ] with you
you don't have perspective I mean it you
accomplished so much already
alright then you don't realize how much
there's more to go wow you know what I
mean seriously because you know when
you're hungry when you're young they've
got all like all these things have
happened it's hard to like understand it
for me to like it's hard to understand
like how much more there is to go right
right yeah man I'm real excited this is
my vision we're gonna I'm gonna make
this the [ __ ] entrepreneurial anthem
that's what I'm gonna do I don't go [ __ ]
what anybody thinks one do together soo
yeah yeah okay let me see I got excited
again I get so competitive that's my
problem it's about to happen
d-roc this is crazy excited now why you
sleep don't funny big boy rhythm Alberto
fight through the night the door Kevin
how's your grab you one buddy
permanently but I need you for anything
like a year ago
I'm making a bush about the bright man
oh yeah would apply
[ __ ] yeah one day five
aw today up there boy y'all anybody I
wanted barley yeah I want it for me mama
you wet the budgets like a star it go
with my mama hi and maybe you know we
have it for so what'd you think mama a
celebration say fulfill your tackle give
the shackle [ __ ] don't complain I say
to kill you bona fide total dud I'm
getting deeper in the car loaded fly low
or nothing keep them free up in my best
hold it there
so what's up no the kid is in demand I
can make it happen body back and eat the
second band double punch just a devil
next edge of cattle net cuddle my [ __ ]
out of line I can trouble cast though
would you ever want to join the baby's
lineage it to study public swimming
watch yourself of mind your business
kill Rob Lowe now let me tell them to
tell them where this helicopter drop and
when enough of you know I will drop your
vehicle right time to support will be
that very good you don't tell her
oh [ __ ] oh yeah what yeah what it
[Music]
[Music]